quarante départements placés en
vigilance orange
fortes tempêtes frappent notre pays ces
dernières 24 heures plusieurs situations
critiques
débordement de fleuves inondations
justin c'est cette tempête tempête
justin qui déferle 17 départements sont
actuellement en zone orange dont un
placés en vigilance rouge le
lot-et-garonne s'est d'ores et déjà une
crue historique grande prudence en si
vous habitez à la montée des eaux fait
craindre le pire aux habitants mais un
autre problème qui envahirent les villes
ce sont les rares chassés de leur
habitat ils sont des milliers à remonter
à la surface
alors la situation va-t-elle profiter à
l'invasion de ces gros rongeur quand la
décrue va-t-elle arriver et surtout nos
villes sont elles en danger alors déjà
je peux vous dire merci merci non mais
parce que franchement plat moi c'est ce
qui m'intéresse le plus en ce moment ils
étaient les spectateurs aussi les 19h50
on est en direct et on a deux sommités
une sommité du climat jean jouzel merci
d'être là jean merci merci moi il faut
que je fous que je m'abonne à canal plus
maintenant abbas a le foot maintenant
c'est sûr favori chiffres gens savaient
quoi soutien de rennes c'est pour moi
c'est cadeau moi c'est cadeau pour
annoncer pour moi ce pour al oula c'est
pour moi aussi
voilà les deux mots qui partent on a on
a notre ami alors lucien cohen plus
connu sous le nom de rachman le sait
mais sûrement et vous êtes une sommité
dans le monde voilà de la baptisation
gens on va d'abord parlé de tout ce
qu'on voit en ce moment c'est vrai que
est ce qu'on peut dire que les
précipitations incroyable auquel on
assiste aujourd'hui sont liés au
réchauffement climatique est ce que
c'est pas normal
en tout cas ça correspond bonsoir un
série de bonsoir correspond à ce à quoi
on s'attend quand même c'est à dire
quand on regarde le récent repart
rapport de météo-france sorti la semaine
dernière qu'est ce qu'il nous dit que
l'hiver est bien les précipitations vont
augmenter ouais c'est le bon sens enfin
ils voient bien ces masses d'air il fait
pas très froid les masses d'air sont
très riches en eau et il ya des
précipitations en fait
mais si on a l'impression de fait
beaucoup plus chaud qu'avant aussi oui
enfin livré un petit j'avais un petit
blouson en nubuck seulement
normalement je m'étais mi-avril
maintenant on descend aujourd'hui je
peux jamais disons clairement par
rapport à ma jeunesse à 2 degrés en
france un degré et demi largement encore
on en rigole mais c'est grave on voit
des événements en vrai vous voyez pas
avant franchement des pluies incroyables
et parfois on voit on voyait les trombes
d'eau
voilà qui tombe pendant 10-15 minutes on
a l'impression donnée dans un climat
tropical
parfois oui justement alors climat
tropical c'est ce qui était évoqué par
mes collègues aussi les nuits tropicales
c'est à dire que l'été alors là on est
l'hiver on a nos problèmes hivernaux que
vous voyez ici mais l'était aussi il ya
ces risques de canicule vraiment avec
ses nuits tropicales que mes collègues
définissent comme des nuits où la
température moyenne est supérieure à 20
degrés en gros tu
on n'est pas très bien après au dessus
de 20 degrés pourra passer la nuit
et c'est cette notion nuit tropicale
c'est la première fois que je la vois
évoqué en france et il pourrait y avoir
si on ne faisait rien pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique
une nuit sur de l'été qui serait de
caractère tropicale donc ce n'est pas à
rien incroyable alors on va voir des
images d ivoire on vous a fait une
petite compile des images les plus
fortes de la montée des eaux qui a
occasionné des situations
catastrophiques dans nos vies de nos
villages d'ailleurs on pense à toutes
les personnes qui sont victimes
voilà deux de ces événements ça c'est
vraiment c'est dramatique pour tous les
gens qui voient parfois toute leur vie
partis revoilà avec ses montées des eaux
je pense à clément guérin d'ailleurs
aussi notre collègue notre pote voilà
qui a été également touchée regarder
[Musique]
alors ça ce que c'est des choses qu'on
voyait avant gens on en a vus avant mais
il ya eu au moins une quarantaine
d'années cette région qu'il n'y a pas eu
de vraiment la garonne n'a pas débordé
depuis une quarantaine d'années ce sont
des événements exceptionnels
malheureusement j'aimerais pouvoir dire
que ça ne se reproduira pas mais ça
risque au contraire de se reproduire
plus fréquemment si on ne fait pas
attention réchauffement climatique c'est
ok des commerces de tous les âges
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire jouer ce
qu'il faut faire ce pas je dirais
simplement respecter les objectifs de la
loi quelle que nous dit la loi que eh
bien on devrait atteindre neutralité
carbone plus émettre de gaz à effet de
serre pratiquement à horizon 2050 que
d'ici 2030 devrait diminuer nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 40%
donc c'est inscrit dans la loi mais nous
ne prenons pas cette loi très au sérieux
puisque nous prenons du retard par
rapport à ce qu'il faudra faire ce qu'il
faudrait faire et bien série chaque fois
qu'on y mette du gaz carbonique
l'utilisation de balles du pétrole du
gaz un père de coûts du charbon chez
nous voilà c'est essentiellement cela
donc on sait ce qu'il faut faire moi
j'ai partagé un an avec les cc 150
citoyens pour le climat qui nous aurons
vraiment fait des propositions
extrêmement intéressantes les
propositions sont là il va y avoir un
nouveau projet de loi qui va en tenir
compte malheureusement partiellement
mais c'est vraiment notre vie de tous
les jours c'est se loger ils ont donc la
mobilité cc lire un voisin
l'alimentation c'est ça quand on voit
les nombreuses habitations qui ont été
touchées par les inondations on aimerait
voilà que ça n'arrive plus certains sont
désespérés n'arrive même plus à se
déplacer dans leur ville regardez vous a
fait une petite compil des témoignages
on pense très fort à toutes ces
personnes regardent les pompiers ont dû
évacuer une quinzaine d'habitants par
bateau on a tous le garage tout le pack
inondées parce qu'on a plus
d'électricité plus d'eau courante
ce soir de nombreuses maisons restent
inondés ce couple doit provisoirement
vivre au premier étage on a insisté
au cours de la journée à monter les eaux
se déplacer devient péri dans le secteur
d'angoulême la barque est même devenu le
seul moyen de quitter son domicile ou
saigne